air marin
la vague dite à la vague
recouvre moi je ma sèche
je ne trouve plus mes algues jeunes
eurac le gravier
encore une autre après toi je retrouve
ma vigueur et m'enfonçant l'océan
l'épave dit à l'épave
unissons nos abandons dans des bols de
porcelaine je verserai mon porto et
l'ivresse des poissons
communiquera nos plaintes aux ermites
des récits
le rocher dit au rocher
depuis des siècles de siècle je
contemple son usure
de nouvelles galeries
s'ouvre dans tes profondeur
palais pour les crustacés
éblouissement de sel
à
l'écu mme ida légumes
demeure encore un instant sur la crête
ou dans les creux
les sons fleurir nos reflets puis nous
nous dissiperont comme les serments des
hommes et les vapeurs de l'été
le
le dit à l'ap
l'horizon s'est effacée
nous réunion dans la distance
à projets décidés
pour changer leur pollution
en jouissent l'est de rouget
désaltérant les jardins
l'orage dit alors ah
dans mes don josé volcan
géant réserve pour toi un arsenal de
tonnerre a déroulé sous tes grêle
et des abf d'éclairs pour séduire des
lois
la laine dit à la laine
laissons les fermer leurs yeux
la campagne se recueille
les bruits prennent leurs tenues du soir
les moteurs s'essouffle une seule goutte
d'eau
suffit à remplir l'espace
marco plan michel
butor